two wacky keys uh you just got back you
were gone i was tell us about why was i
i was about to trip
were you doing peyote or something you
just kept texting me you loved me to the
point i didn't know how to respond i
dude i was in a [ __ ] bad spot we're
getting on that plane um
it was like hey what's up
all right i love you guys you're like
alright thanks man
hey hey just checking in it's lunch time
love you guys i'm like alright man it
was about 4 00 a.m in hawaii when i was
sending those texts uh yeah we
um
well let's go back man
i guess we wouldn't have to cut this but
hang on
no no no no no no no no nothing we have
to cut
no nothing
i i just don't i don't know if i can say
this or not
did you be the judge of that i'm
terrible at that is this about something
will this implicate me or is this about
your trip me my my trip then what do you
mean you're the one who decides if you
can say that or not well okay so
we um you know we were you came back
dumber somehow
jesus i mean the conversations we were
having before we started
whoa whoa man
i was like he's gonna come back we're
going to be refreshed he's like nine
points dumber
i ate i ate a whole tube of surf wax
while i was over there
which apparently is poisonous
[Laughter]
drop me on my head um jesus christ
enough with the same one you know we
were burning the candle at both ends we
had a very vigorous schedule for the two
months leading up to you going away sure
and it it caught up to all of us we were
all exhausted we were tired we were sick
[ __ ] voices were gone where our our
mental state
terrible i mean i i felt like we were in
the middle of [ __ ] fallujah
[ __ ] when we did uh we did we did
schultzy's we opened up schultzy's
residency
at new york comedy club you
bombed bomb oh man the big man took a
hot one i bombed in front of scooter
braun i know
[Laughter]
i did well i s i have the tape i saw him
laughing at him i bombed in front of one
of the biggest managers in the world but
he still manages justin bieber yeah but
they got busted for stealing taylor
swift cds or something like that he
didn't steal old cds
he bought the rights to her music
i heard it was a b a i don't know about
you guys
there's only one copy so we're cut we're
coming off hot i mean we're [ __ ] we're
touching gold here at this point [ __ ]
gosh
gotham was fantastic [ __ ] philly when
philly philly skankfest
new york
then we're recording this whole time too
because we're traveling right
then gramercy with the boys gramercy the
schultzy thing that's where i started to
that's where this all started to
i felt the walls closing in on me yeah
they were before
from the outside looking and you were
struggling a week before that yeah i
don't know that one day in uh
that week in therapy we just opened up a
can of worms and it was like i was back
to square one
and i was really feeling it that friday
night i just couldn't relax i couldn't
there was just something and then
you know but you know we're doing the
job and stuff like that schultzy's
crowds are always [ __ ] awesome
they're always great it's always a
[ __ ] layup uh whenever he has a show
at new york comedy club that i've hosted
um
and this one it was just a [ __ ] buzz
saw like they were either nervous to see
him or there was a lot of videos you
stink or i stink one of them but man i
walked up there and [ __ ] talking
about from the frying pan and the fire
just [ __ ]
just [ __ ] two by fours in the face
and i didn't make adjustments i just
[ __ ] kept i saw you hit your closer
oh
i saw you hit a bit too literal
nothing like actual zilch like
it was i was punk
i was punting on first down you might as
well been in space dude because
it was [ __ ] dead
silent oh you were just out there
floating like the moon man just [ __ ]
eating it oh yeah so
they just that i did well
based purely off that i was not you yes
like they were like this because they
just did not like you
and that happens a lot of times it's
like for whatever reason they don't like
you
the next person just by
they were still all bit wonky the crowd
yeah like there was one or two things
that i had that fell really fast they
didn't really loosen up until after
schultz got off stage i feel like there
was it like the air wasn't toby got on
we'll get in there ate my
um
i forgot about this whole night oh man
you i couldn't get you on that plane
soon enough away from me to relax
telling you dude holy [ __ ]
yeah that was [ __ ] instant section
eight get this kid [ __ ] out of here
so
it gets worse
so
um
[Music]
so yeah i felt like there was just
anticipation of that because once
schultzy got off and and mark got up
there they was everything was like they
know and like him yeah so they're all
characters well i thought they knew and
liked me too apparently i was wrong why
would they know you scoot what's up kid
skater
peter b yo skeeter brown what are you
doing
you got taylor swift's number
tell that pale [ __ ] i said what up hey
shooter mcgavin do me a favor how about
a chuckle for the big guy over here i'm
[ __ ] bombing up here plus he had two
goons with him i was killing with the
goons really i got it on camera and you
can see them [ __ ] lean and elbowing
i'm photoshopping
put your head up put a couple other
celebrities in the crowd
anyway anywho
what so let's let's talk about that so i
come off stage obviously my head's in
the [ __ ] toilet i'm [ __ ] i'm
outside talking to toby he's [ __ ]
don't worry about it you did great
talking me up this that the other thing
i'm like man such a big game oh my god
and then it turns out that they needed
somebody to do the old checkerinos the
check spot tough spot
especially on that show
so kippy brings up uh to our to to to to
one of our
reno joey bagarino the manager over
there um
hey why don't i let toby do it yeah he's
like we need a comic i said t-bones here
t-bone was not in that conversation no
then we the three of us walked up to
toby
all right the two of you i said it looks
like you're doing checks what do you
mean ago i just said you were doing no
no no no no ladies and gentlemen the
color ran from his face
as if jack the ripper had sliced open
his his carotid artery or whatever it's
called yeah i'm talking talk about
changing your tune oh dude i went from
you know what happened he was about to
fake an asthma attack
god damn
he just picks up a bottle of purell
for the listener what the check spot is
is it's an unfortunate casualty of the
new york comedy club and the way it has
to function not new york coming up
specifically but every uh every comedy
showcase i can't wait till the end to do
the checks because people will run out
they run out so you gotta have a check
spot five ten minutes to give the
servers a chance to [ __ ] get the
bills and they typically put up a young
it's like the apprenticeship to get into
a club right it's like every a lot of
people go through it to do that you get
to get into a club it's where our boys
even even if it's beneath you yeah it's
where our boy tommy cassidy made his
bones you gotta you start doing master
and then they'll give you like a late
night wednesday night spot and then you
work your way in toby's case but
normally
oh my god but it's also it's like so
you're trying to tell jokes after the
show you're set hold on you're set up to
fail like yeah success rate is maybe
maybe if you do them a bunch
maybe 50
everyone in the room is finding out they
just paid 12 dollars for a miller light
yeah yeah if probably more than that
yeah they're all look who had the
chicken fa a lot and also a lot of
people are good now they just drop it
with the card and like whatever yeah but
if it's a group of people they start it
it's everybody's just talking for the
first minute but joe says to toby he's
like it's going to be about 10 or 15
minutes and i didn't know that kobe's
like 10 minutes would be great yeah
15 would be a complete nightmare
so he said
let's make sure it's not 15.
for the landlord's sake
i don't want to ruin people's
thanksgiving
but no toby's too hard on himself he
went up and did a good job i was the one
that [ __ ] steered us into the iceberg
yeah
which i don't i was there with two
buckets i'm trying to keep it up and i
jumped in with an anvil i tried this guy
from the top rope
thinking he's gonna save the day
swan dives
pocahontas out here hi you're like
mickey rook at the end of the wrestler
[ __ ] one last body slam
heart attack right in midair
but i i've learned because usually
denzel and a man on fire just walking
over the bridge
a life for a life
i just watched that too
oh my god that'll that'll tear you up
that'll jerk you up oh man are you
kidding me i'm the sheep that got lost
madre
oh that's a good one oh i was bawling my
eyes out um
i almost started crying oh my god i love
you
you see dude i can't he said i love you
like 14 times one day i'm cracking up
over here
um
hey you guys want to record on whatever
you want i love you man all right
i uh uh
used to wear my
heart on my sleeve with that like i was
just boogies
you had to look to see if there was
boogies
that's not because it my shirt would be
flipped up i flip them up and that's how
i put my
keep my boogies on the inside
he gives out a little snack later um
i i was bad at that for a long time like
if i didn't do well i would come out and
announce it to everybody hi i [ __ ]
stink i still do that but the better
thing is hey it was great see you later
nobody knows any wiser to the to a
degree yeah you're making you make a lot
of noise people know so i tried to keep
up good appearances especially i walked
in the green room told chelsea it was
going up in a couple minutes i'm like
hey buddy i'm gonna let him a couple
minutes everything's great they're doing
great have a good time right i don't
know if he got wind that i
stunk either was it all was it on in
there was it was it playing it wasn't on
but you know
who to that room
everybody when you're in that green room
i do when you're in that green room you
can tell if the person is doing good or
bad was it disgust hey he's not doing
that great no
i mean not in the circles i was in maybe
when i you know and when i popped out to
go pee pee or something but they know
we're boys so they might have been
trashing you behind my back which i
would have encouraged
i would have been upset if they left me
out of that
halfway through the set listen feel free
gentlemen yeah like this bad guy stinks
right
i'm starting it